INSTRUCTOR: And one of
the challenges that we've
seen time and time again,
is that there's often
a gap between data scientists
and those stakeholders
they're hoping to inform.
And that gap a lot of
times is the result
of different mediums.
So that creates
a problem for us,
is that if we just wait
for decision makers
to proactively go
visit our work,
we're not actually
closing that gap.
Now that's one problem.
We also see something
else kind of interesting
happen as do the science teams
trying to close this gap.
One thing as we said, is
that maybe the dashboards
fall by the wayside.
Another thing that
can often happen
is that stakeholders
will get excited,
they'll say great this
insight makes sense,
can you bring it to my
medium, can you copy and paste
those predictions
into my spreadsheet,
or can you send me a
screenshot of that plot
so I can put it in
my presentation?
And that leads to a lot of
painful labor-intensive work.
But I'd like to
propose for you today
an alternative, a
solution that we've
found a lot of success using
ourselves here at RStudio.
So what does the
solution entail?
Instead of creating a
dashboard, what we like to do
is create a proactive notifier.
Or something that is going to
alert me to the information
that I need to know.
And in our case, we
spend most of our time
inside of our inboxes, so
that's where our alerts goes,
is through email.
And so that's what we're
going to talk about today,
is how you can use a
rich set of R-packages
to allow you to create these
proactive notifications.
Oftentimes these
notifications need
to meet the expectations
of our stakeholders
for how they're
formatted, so we'll
look at some new packages
that are available to help you
precisely format these results.
And then finally, we don't want
to solve this dashboard fatigue
problem by introducing
another type of fatigue, which
would be email
fatigue, and so we're
going to talk about
how you can only send
these alerts on conditions.
So that instead of
sending emails every day,
it can send emails
more specifically when
there's a problem at hand.
We also don't want to introduce
data science fatigue so we're
going to talk about
how we can achieve
these proactive notifications
in an automated way.
The picture that
you're seeing here
is one of my favorite
examples of this workflow.
And one of my
roles at RStudio is
to keep track of all
the different R-packages
that we build and maintain.
For some of you on
the line, R-packages
might be a newer thing.
So briefly they're sort of
the bread and butter of how
data science gets done
in R. They're also
one of the main
things that we're
responsible for at
RStudio, it's creating
these different packages.
And so every day we go and we
build all of these packages
and we want to know if
any of those builds fail.
Especially if it's a
really popular package.
We don't want to get a
whole bunch of emails
from users saying,
hey, this package
isn't available or doesn't work.
We want to stay ahead of
those types of problems.
And so what a data scientist
named Greg and I came up with,
is this workflow,
where every day
we run these builds and
then if there's a problem
and critically, only
if there's a problem,
do we get these types
of targeted emails
that tell me exactly
what the problem was
and allow me to then
take further action.
We're not the only
ones who are using
this pattern successfully.
So I just want to tell
you a few quick stories
before we get into the
weeds of writing the code.
One of my favorite stories is
from a large infrastructure
as a service provider.
So a company that maintains
thousands if not hundreds
of thousands of servers.
And what they use
this workflow to do,
was track their hardware uptime.
And then if they saw
a problem arising they
could send a proactive
alert out to their vendors,
in the context of their support
level agreement through SLA.
And what this team was
really excited about,
is before adopting this workflow
they had done this type of task
in Jira.
And any time they onboarded
a new vendor or they modified
their SLA, they had
to manually click
through a whole bunch
of steps in Jira
to accomplish this task.
The great thing
about this workflow
is that it's all based on
code, so it's really easy
to reuse these different
rules and different markdown
documents that you're
going to write.
And so this allowed the
team to easily cut down
their onboarding time.
Another really awesome story
of this type of technology
applied, was a high tech
manufacturer of people
ops department, so
kind of an HR group.
And they had this
challenging task
where they needed
to notify division
managers about employee
overtime problems.
So say an employee
worked more overtime
than they were allowed, they
wanted to send out an alert.
And before they had
a dashboard and what
they found was their 30
different division managers,
were not reliably going to
that dashboard every day
to check if there was problems.
And so they adopted
this workflow
to instead send out
an email to a manager,
only if there was
actually a problem
with a specific employee's
over time submission.
And they actually won
an award of excellence
for adopting this
workflow, which
I think is really exciting
because it's ultimately
a pretty simple concept that
we're talking about here.
And so if they're able
to win excellence awards
I think that's going to be
accessible to a lot of teams
as well.
So this is our main document,
our main report in Connect.
So it looks great.
We actually have a history
of these documents,
they'll be published every day.
But to do that you
have to set it up.
You actually have to go to
schedule and then schedule
this output to be run every day.
So it'll take all code
it'll run it everyday,
maybe on different data,
that's kind of the hope.
Because what happens is,
you'll be [INAUDIBLE]
a different datasource.
Well the same
datasource, but it will
be updated every single day.
So we'll get different data
and possibly different alerts.
So in this day, we did
have a few problems
that are lined here in red.
So that's great, but we
have to check this every day
to see that there's a problem.
When we send email, we can
send it when there's a problem
and we don't have
to be checking.
This is almost the same
problem as the dashboard
having to report here.
But the email
solves that problem.
So to schedule that, we schedule
every day and the key thing
is to send an
email after update.
And we set some recipients.
It could be Sean,
for instance here.
OK, sorry we have
to go here first
and have him be as part of
the [INAUDIBLE] on the list.
Sean.
Great, now we can save that.
And now we have a master list of
people that can view or change
this document.
And we can schedule Connect to
send emails to those recipients
through here.
So I'll just do
this one more time.
This is kind of cool.
Great, and we'll save this.
Brilliant.
So every day it's
going to be run
and we can change
this of course.
But this is daily
data, so it makes sense
to send it every day.
And it will send an email
only if the thresholds
were exceeded.
And we can actually
preview the email.
Send one to yourself, just to
debug the email and make sure
it looks good before
it actually goes out
before it goes to production.
So I can send this.
And I actually happen
to have one open.
So it shows it to me right here.
This is my email client.
We can see that
the subject here is
one of our KPIs and
parentheses three, that's
the blue work that we did here,
total exceed broke thresholds
and we have the list of
things here, which is great
because if you look at this
in your list of messages
you see this right away before
even opening up the email.
And the body looks really good.
This actually looks really
wonderful on a small device
because the text is quite large.
We have just the
important things
which are the table, a little
bit of text, just to sort
of show what's being
shown and importantly,
here's the attachment.